who was The Mastermind if you go down
there and you read uh what most of the
uh Brave journalists in Mexico that we
have
say another aspect of this war is that a
lot of journalists get killed I think
Mexico has a I think has some of the top
numbers in the world
and this is not no secret to anybody uh
El Mayo sambada is the is the name of
the the historical figurehead of this
cartel or at least somebody who people
theorize or suspect to be the uh the the
main guy or the main person that is in
charge of some of this criminal group is
he still alive
that's the going rumor that he's still
very much alive the interesting thing
about him is that he learned his craft
in Los Angeles so people thinking that
scene Laura cartel isn't a Mexican thing
it's actually
he he apparently learned a lot of his
craft from uh people in the United
States you know and that's the craft of
leadership to craft the business the
craft which aspect of the craft the
craft of getting a product from Colombia
putting it through Mexico and then
Logistics the logistics part of it
you know and he somehow is uh
operating in the shadows so he's not a
known entity I don't have a clear number
of this but he was interviewed by a
magazine called processo in Mexico and
some pictures were taken of him this was
over 10 years ago probably and that's
the last time anybody's ever seen a
picture of them what's it like to be a
journalist in that so uh can a
journalist have a conversation with him
and live not unless he asks to to have
that conversation I think he he reached
out to this journalist to talk about it
um there's a there's a media Wing to the
work that we do a sister page called
demolar
and and it's run by some pretty good
people and the way we met is that that
was basically training them how to work
in hostile environments and they were
like oh we're gonna go report on cartel
activity in Mexico
and I was like you know that is
a year and a half ago a reporter went to
the president's Daily Briefing uh press
conference that he has they called him
la mananeras president and the president
Manuel Lopez and told him to his face
like uh I have threats on my life
they're trying to kill me
and it happened there's been a slew of
assassinations and murders of members of
the press all over Mexico it's not an
easy job uh
either they say too much or they say
things that favor one side or the other
which is another aspect of it that is
interesting I don't I don't consider
myself a reporter I don't report on the
news in Mexico I have friends that do
that very well I commented on some of it
only uh but you see a lot of these uh
cartel reporters go down there talk to a
specific side and basically speak one
side of the story and that is not
something that the other side wants you
know if you
if you go down there and speak to one
side you're saying what they want people
to know or hear so in a way you're kind
of spreading some of their cartel
propaganda in a way and that's how some
people
you know get shot do you think it's
possible
to go in there and have a conversation
with a cartel leader well Sean Penn for
somebody like me for somebody like Sean
Penn this is what I will say uh after
after that whole Sean Penn thing I think
a lot of people would reconsider the
meeting with anybody of any level that
has any notoriety here in the United
States they don't they wouldn't trust
anybody to get that close
um there are people out there that will
talk to reporters you know people that
are working on a on a lab laboratory
somewhere in a hillside somewhere down
down south you know in the Sierra
uh you know low-level people that get
authorization to speak to reports and
stuff like that but they don't say
anything that isn't being taught or
shown in various different ways or
Outlets out there for them I mean some
of these guys have Instagram accounts
you know some of these guys that blog
about it you know they're not the
leaders Tick Tock no not the leaders I
think after what happened to dual Chapel
Guzman I think that that uh that
opportunity that window was closed uh
for for some of the leadership down
there I think I disagree I think they're
just more sensitive
realizing that there has to be a deep
trust it's not just anybody and not any
high profile I've gotten a chance to
speak to some very high profile leaders
that don't speak to journalists and they
understand the value of trust
if they have something to say which I
don't think they do you know I don't
think they let unless at some point in
the future which is something I suspect
might it might be coming
that there is some sort of armed
intervention and or external attack on
some of these criminal groups
that really puts the pressure on them
you don't think there's a human aspect
to this of a human being wanting their
story to be known versus versus this is
different than the propaganda machine of
I have something to say I have some
message to put out there to play the
game of politics and power and money and
all that kind of stuff isn't there also
a human being underneath all that armor
that
for for the sake of perhaps ego Legacy
wants to be understood I think in a way
they already do that there's Corridos
which are basically Mexican folk songs
that get uh they get uh song about some
of them so in a way some of these some
of these singers are reporting on some
of their lives and it's like a it's a
great honor to have a corrido made about
you you know I somebody somebody made a
courage about me based on my interviews
right yeah I didn't pay for it so it's a
real one yeah it's it feels cool so
creating a myth the legend of the man
I think it's about uh I think a way you
can you can find somebody like that is
somebody that wants to get their story
specifically clear and straight uh you
know
coming from that culture and getting to
work for the government down there and
then not being not working for the
government down there and being on the
outside being critical of not only the
government that is in place now but also
the government that actually work with
I can tell you that there's villains all
over the place down there everybody's a
villain you know at all levels in in
some way shape or form and some of these
people
I think in a way including El Chapo I
think that some of that that meeting was
about film rights and and stories and
being able to get his story out there I
think I don't I'm not I'm not too sure
because I wasn't there but I suspect
that some of that was going on
if you can bring an honest voice down
there they can trust to put that out
there yeah I mean
I think I think he could try I'm
interested in that kind of thing I
um because ultimately in some of those
places
like
inside a cartel at the very top is when
you can really look at the raw aspects
of human nature anyway you can't
necessarily elsewhere there's a youth
coming into power down there and when I
say a youth I mean some of the old guard
is going out and some of the new guard
is coming in an example of this is uh El
Chapo Guzman's sons who are now in their
own right kind of getting gaining
legendary status uh his uh his son there
was an attempted arrest on his son that
led to
the famous School yakanaso incident
which we are now learning more about
because some of the guacamaya leagues
are kind of speaking more about what
happened that day
uh basically a federal operation uh to
they say to to arrest El Chapo Guzman's
son
um
turn into a Siege to try and get them
free they called in the calvary
basically the whole of the Sinaloa
cartel showed up to try and rescue him
interesting thing about that is in
reading some of the documents and also
just seeing some of the videos and stuff
like that came out of that incident
the cartels were the ones evacuating the
citizenship from the area
they were the ones going restaurant to
restauranting if you want to exit the
city go through here take your families
get down but you have to leave because
the army's coming here they're going to
fight us
um so there's like a deep morality too
to all of that underneath the violence
there's a Humanity I mean it's their
home it is their home and they were
fighting for their home and they were
fighting for leadership from their home
uh there is a morality there is a
Humanity there and again
I don't if people want to paint them all
with the villainy aspects you know uh
that's I mean everybody's a villain and
every in somebody else's story you know
if we if you kind of look at it that way
people should check out your patreon
should you check out your field notes yo
you're a really good writer your
Instagram too you write about you have a
quote in your field notes about villains
quote I once worked for a villain a
savior to some and a biblical demon of
old to others a true product of his
environment
he was the best and the worst of us were
all potential villains in someone else's
story he would say to us as you as we
would head out into the unknowns that
the Knight had waiting for us it was
during one of these nights that looked
around me and saw horns and pitchforks
among my people and realized what he
meant
we were no Knights of the Round Table
whatever we were we were needed in the
end I guess that justified most of what
was about to happen uh do you think El
Chapo do you think people like him are
good or evil
I think there's no one without the other
I think there's a there's a cost to
there's a cost to uh their goodness that
they do you know the roads they build
the hospitals the career paths that they
pay for uh there's there are doctors in
Mexico that their careers were paid for
by some of these groups
uh and they do a lot of amazing good for
the community I remember there was a
a surgeon
uh reconstructing cleft palates
in one of my travels that I did out
there I I had I spent some time actually
going out there be after I got out of
the job to train people and the the type
of stuff that I show people and uh they
uh they told me like I told them like
you're doing God's work this stuff this
stuff is like legit this is God's work
you know building Smiles for people and
so yeah and then can I talk to you yeah
he said you know my career path was paid
for by
cartel a group of cartel members they
paid for my career path because they
wanted somebody on hand that could fix
their teeth
do you think some aspects of that is
just sort of manipulative control
or is some of it also just again a care
for the population for fellow human
beings that are one of your own I think
both you know I think there's again
that's hard to it's hard to just make
them Saints or Devils you know the uh
the the some of the good they do in some
of their communities and don't ask
anything for in return you know uh and
even if they don't ask it for anything
in return where the military shows up
they are immediately met with rocks and
roadblocks and everybody's uh
main weapon down there which is most
Mexicans can't buy or own firearms
they're the main weapon down there is
silence and their eyes to report to the
people that they uh consider the good
guys in their environment right
so
that's a hard question you know I think
I think there's a bit of both and both
the the government and the criminal
groups that are operating down there
silence is their main weapon